Another important monadic image processing
operation is gamma correction, and I am going
to talk now about the problem of gamma.
Back in the early days of television, the
display device of choice was the cathode ray
tube and the cathode tube is a very non-linear
device.
So for an input voltage V, the brightness
on the screen, which I am going to call L
for luminance, was the power of the input
voltage.
In fact, it was almost a square law, so that
is; the luminance of a point on the screen
was about the square of the input voltage—the
input voltage raised to the power of 2.2.
So this number, 2.2, is referred to as the
gamma of the display device.
So this is a bit of a difficulty.
The output luminance is not linearly proportional
to the input voltage.
Now let’s add a camera to the system.
So the camera looks at the world and it sees
luminance L and it converts that to a voltage.
The voltage is transmitted to the television
receiver, and the television receiver produces
a luminance, which is related to the input
voltage raised to the power of gamma.
And what happens now is that our system is
not linear from end to end.
The luminance that I see on my screen is the
original luminance raised to the power of
gamma, and that is going to have a really
bad effect on contrast.
If one part of the original image is twice
as bright as another on the screen that I
am looking at, it will appear to be almost
four times greater in brightness.
So to get around this problem the early television
engineers pulled a pretty neat trick.
And what they did is they inserted the inversed
non-linearity into the camera: the luminance
that I see on my TV screen is proportional
to the luminance of the scene that the TV
camera was looking at.
The system now is linear from end to end.
And that is great for the person viewing the
TV image.
So the process within the camera is referred
to as gamma encoding and the image between
the camera and the TV screen is referred to
as a gamma encoded image.
And the process of gamma decoding, or sometimes
called gamma correction, happens within the
display screen.
Now where this is relevant today is those
gamma encoded images are what we record in
image files.
So if I take a standard image file format,
a jpeg file or whatever, the pixel values
within that file have been gamma encoded.
They are not linearly related to the luminance
of the scene that the camera is looking at.
And in the header of almost any image file
format there is an entry there, which says:
what’s the gamma setting that has been used
in the camera.
The reason that this is still convenient even
though cathode ray tubes have long gone is
that those image pixels in the image file
are going to be displayed on your screen,
and as I said before even modern screens emulate
the old cathode ray tube non-linearity.
So it is really important to remember that
the pixel values within an image file are
not linearly related to the real world luminance.
They are related to that luminance to the
power of 1 over gamma; in fact, it is almost
a square root function.
So we can do gamma correction, we can treat
that as a monadic function.
The function is basically we take every input
pixel and raise it to the power of gamma.
And we can see that there is basically a parabolic
shape to this mapping.
And if we apply it to an image and look at
it, we see that the image looks very, very
dark indeed.
And the reason for that is that what I have
done is gamma corrected this image twice.
I have gamma corrected the image by applying
this monadic function and then my screen,
or your screen, has applied the gamma correction
again.
So it can be useful to apply gamma correction
if you want to look at and manipulate the
pixel values, because you want them to be
proportional to the original light levels
in the scene, but to display a gamma corrected
image on a monitor is not a useful thing to
do.